okay so um i'm going to
switch around my slides a little bit
after seeing peter orban's talk on the
first day to give you
a little more overview of of what it
means to do relational learning so you
can understand better the
sort of key message that i want to
convey about a series of work that i'll
show you so i have three
pieces of work from two of my phd
students who've now graduated ruang
jiang zhang and hoda el-dardiri and so i
won't go over the technical details of
that work but i just want to highlight a
couple findings that we have
been thinking about in relation
to the effect of the graph structure
that on these networks that we're
modeling and the performance
of machine learning methods that want to
do
we need to do estimation and prediction
in these networks and so i guess first i
should clarify the difference uh let me
go to this slide uh clarify the
difference between what i'll talk about
and what art talked about at the
beginning so really what
we focus on is learning predictive
models of attributes in
attributed networks where we have the
nodes or people or computer hosts or
events the edges in the graph are
relationships between those users and
then we have some set of attributes or
covariates on the nodes so we might have
some class label here that i'm coloring
as red and green which is our y's that
we're trying to predict and we have a
bunch of other observed attributes x
that we'll use to improve that
prediction but we're also exploiting the
graph structure so a big difference
between
what art talked about
and what we work on is generally if we
focus on discrete data rather than
continuous data and the kriging models
that he was talking about and also um i
think
in the set of work that i'll talk about
here we want to learn the models of the
relationships in the graph
from one part of the graph and then
generalize to other parts of the graph
instead of the semi-supervised kind of
frame or i was talking about
however there are other similarities
that i'll try to point out as i go
through the talk so there's been a lot
of work over the last 10 or 15 years on
developing methods that can do
prediction in this kind of domain
and basically a number of them can be
characterized as modeling the full joint
distribution over the y values which are
the class labels on the nodes
conditioned on the observed x attributes
that we have and the graph structure
okay and
so we have a lot of empirical success on
learning these kind of models and using
them to improve predictions in the
networks and i'll show you that examples
in a second but the key message that i
want to give today is that
in the machine learning community in the
statistical relational learning
community we focused on doing this kind
of modeling and what we haven't really
thought much about is this graph
structure over here that we're
conditioning on and it turns out that
the structure of these graphs actually
affect how our models
work both in terms of how the estimation
methods work but also in terms of how
the prediction methods work and so i'll
try to elaborate that on that a little
bit in this talk i guess i should
explain this conditional distribution so
we also instead of modeling the full
joint distribution some methods model
the conditional distribution of
predicting a particular label y i
conditioned on the attributes of both
that node and its neighboring nodes and
the class labels of those neighbors as
well and so basically the graph
structure
gives us the mechanism
by which we identify other related nodes
in the graph that we then we can use
their labels to improve prediction
so that's what we're trying to exploit
and here are some examples
of networks where we apply these kind of
models so it ranges from looking at
social networks like what lotta talked
about before the break of trying to
predict properties of people let's say
in facebook predicting their political
views or their religious views based on
their relationship to their friends in
the network to also uh
gene and protein networks like bin
talked about earlier where maybe we want
to predict the protein function based on
its interactions with other proteins in
the cell okay
and so the key
sort of challenges in this
area of relational learning are what we
focused on for the last 10 or 15 years
is that all of the methods that were
developed in traditional or conventional
machine learning where we assumed that
the data were independent and
identically distributed instances that
no longer holds in these network domains
and so we have heterogeneous
interdependent instances we might have
partially observed networks with
partially observed uh labels which is
the kind of thing that art was talking
about the networks themselves might be
dynamic or non-stationary and a sort of
key difference with anybody who's from
the structured machine learning
community here is that we often focus on
data from a single network or a small
number of networks so we don't have many
many replicas of these networks where we
can talk about asymptotics as we observe
an infinite number of networks over time
okay so
the general form of the models that i'll
talk about today can be characterized as
markovian relational models where this
applies to both
relational markov networks markov logic
networks and relational dependency
networks there's probably others that
fall in this same general category
that i'm not aware of at this point
but the form of these models are that we
take a model template which we're
calling which we can talk about as
clique templates and we have these
little model templates that the way that
we deal with heterogeneity in this graph
is we take these little templates and we
roll them out over the graph to
construct
this likelihood like we have here so we
have uh we're here i'm pulling the graph
structure out here but we're trying to
model the joint labels over all of the
examples and here we have a product over
all possible templates clique templates
then we have instantiations of those
templates and then we have the features
of those templates in the model and so
that might look like a template might
look like in this graph right here where
you have the green nodes and all the
brown nodes that they're connected to
you might have a template
that applies in that case and looks at
the features of those kind of nodes and
then you would roll
that out
in all of the places that it applies in
this particular form of the network and
so what you can notice here is that if
you had a template like this you would
have to deal with the fact that this
green node right here has eight
neighbors but this uh green node down
here only has seven neighbors right so
there has to be
some kind of aggregation or something
that deals deals with the heterogeneity
that way okay
and so here's the um
part of the slides that i've added in
since this workshop has started
i think what
gets lost a lot when we just look at
math like i just showed you is actually
how that's operationalized you know in
these networks and what kind of models
we're actually uh talking about and so
there's a big difference between well
not a big difference but an important
difference between what i would call the
data network and the model network that
uh that we end up using for modeling and
so as michael alluded to at the
beginning this really
comes into play because what we do is
essentially roll out a graphical model
over the network that we observe and so
the way that that
looks like is that we might have a data
network right here where these would be
people and their friendship
relationships in facebook or something
like that
and in contrast to people that are just
modeling the graph structure what we now
think about is that we have a number of
attributes on each of those nodes
and so then the data network really
looks like this to us where we now have
these nodes that have a number of
attribute values in them and now i've
colored them again according to their
class label for example if we're trying
to predict um let's see which one did i
do
political views we have the democrats
colored as green and the republicans are
conservatives colored as red right so
this is still our view of the data
network and now when we're going to
learn a model of this in this general
graphical model framework that i talked
about we're going to take our little
model template where here i've used
relatively simple cliques where these
are the kind of cliques you might use in
an ied scenario where you're talking
about the relationship between our three
different
covariates here and their
relationship with the class label that
we're trying to predict but then also we
have this additional i think i animated
that this is the sort of key relational
part of the model where we have a
template that looks at the relationship
between the y values on neighboring
nodes in the graph and so now once we've
defined
this
model template
what we do is put that together with the
data network and then that will roll out
over the entire data network to create
this complex graphical model that we'll
use for learning and inference
and i should point out that this
graphical model
will look different on the network that
we use for estimation
and
compared to the network that we will use
for prediction because the structure of
that network might differ a little bit
right so what you can see here is we
have these little templates that are
rolled out over each of the nodes in the
graph and then and then we have the
connections between the y values okay
oh and i had that animated to just show
you here
this was the underlying data network
that a lot of networks people would uh
present to you and talk about modeling
right so so the key uh the key point
that i want to make here is that the
structure of this rolled out graphical
model that we're going to use for
learning at inference uh depends on the
structure of the data network that
that we're using for analysis and this
particular kind of structure
can impact the performance of our models
and so in contrast with uh graphical
model people who try to reason about the
performance of arbitrary graphical
models that you know maybe have nice
structures like trees or
maybe talk about cases where the cycles
cause problems in the inference um now
we're doing the kinds of graphical
models we deal with have very specific
kinds of structure because they have the
properties that have been talked about
you know all through this workshop that
we have these very specific kinds of
social network properties right and so
in particular they're sparse and likely
to be clustered okay
and i should note also at this point
that i showed you a relatively simple
example where i could lay the original
data network over top of exactly the
graphical model that i constructed but
if you had more complex clique templates
that considered more than just binary
pairwise cliques between the users
this graphical model structure would get
much harder to draw right and so that's
why many of us that gives talks on on
these kind of models we don't end up
drawing these graphical model structures
for you we just show you the math right
okay
okay so then
what we generally try
how we generally apply these models is
that we take so if we have some big
large facebook network we would take
some
small subgraphs sampled from that larger
network where that graph is fully
labeled so we see all the class labels
that we're interested in we estimate the
parameters of the model from this fully
labeled subgraph and then generally what
we do is we have some other part of the
network where we want to apply that for
prediction and when we apply it for
prediction generally we know some of the
labels of the nodes in this network and
so then it's similar to the kind of
setting that art was talking about where
we have partial observations in this
network and we roll out that graphical
model and we do joint inference given
the parameters that we had learned
and so when we roll out that graphical
model
and we have partially observed
information about the class labels of
the nodes that also changes the
structure of the graphical model so here
i'm just showing you the same
rolled out version that i showed you
before but let's say for node four right
here we actually know its class label
when we go to do inference then the
effect of that is that
it breaks up the network because of the
markov property right
so
once
i guess i'm i'm showing this in a little
bit of a
clues right because this known label can
actually tell you something about these
labels
y2 and y3 over here but it essentially
because of the markov property means
this information here does not flow over
here and same for this information over
there right and so when this particular
node is known you can almost think of it
as two separate inference problems
because the network breaks apart right
and that's a very different situation
than
if we know this node over here
oh i went too fast
because then you're only going to break
off this little part of the network and
and then you'll still have to do joint
inference over here right so going back
to the question that i think matt asked
art about what happens when you're the
labels that you have to seed things are
not randomly distributed throughout the
network this shows why that can vastly
change the kinds of results that you get
because now we have to do joint
inference over a much larger part of the
network and if you happen to have a lot
of labels that are randomly spread
throughout this network so if we have 80
or 90 percent of the nodes we know the
labels that means effectively you're not
you're not doing inference over very
large subgraphs right it breaks it up
very nicely into a bunch of little small
sections where you can do inference very
accurately
but this might all sound very obvious to
you at this point
but
we didn't tend to draw these things for
ourselves right so as sofas knows we
we painfully came to this understanding
over uh many years of getting
very distinctly different performance
from different methods and different
scenarios of label availability
okay so um
so i have three main findings that i
want to talk about in terms of
how the work that i've done lately with
my students have started to
sort of highlight how the graph
structure impacts the performance of
these models and
some of you have seen some of this work
already because i've talked you know in
the stat department here and other
places in the bay area and so
i'm not going to go over the technical
details but just kind of highlight the
conclusions that you might get from this
work and so the first set of work
was
an effort that we did on developing
copula models for this kind of data
which i'll get to in a second but the
important conclusion of that work is
that um
when we started doing work in relational
learning to begin with we looked at this
iid assumption that conventional machine
learning had had made for many years
which is that the instances were
independent and identically distributed
and we worked on removing the
independence assumption right because we
explicitly wanted to uh
exploit the relationship between users
and their dependents to make better
predictions but what we forgot about was
the other eye
for a long time
and so
i guess we still and and i'm sure that
sofas will remember this we still you
know we still talked about how
instances yeah users are users right we
think of those as being identically
distributed that's what our that's what
these templates try to do to say really
you know if you take a pair of users
people are
essentially the same right if you know
nothing else about them the sort of
likelihood that they share the same uh
political views is you know roughly the
same across all people right or that
that's one of the reasons that we can
apply these models because we want to
say we take one large network we don't
just have one sample we have a sample of
n nodes in that network right and maybe
our effective sample size which has come
up throughout the workshop is not
exactly n but you know it's something
far away from one right we have we have
enough data there in the network to be
able to uh make uh
to estimate the parameters of the model
and so
i guess i always thought
that the way we define these models was
essentially
still assuming that our nodes were
identically distributed but actually if
you look at the way these graphical
models work because they depend on the
structure of the network
they
the nodes are not marginally invariant
right so if we know nothing about
anybody in this network when we make a
prediction about
the class label of a
we're going to
marginalize over everything in their
neighborhood right and and although
there's nothing there we'll marginalize
over the fact that we don't know
anything in that neighborhood and so
that actually won't be the same
prediction
if we make
this do the same activity for this node
e right here right because although we
still don't know anything about the
people in his neighborhood
we
know
nothing about less people
if that's if that makes sense right so
because
this node has only three neighbors here
it's different than this node over here
which has four neighbors okay and so we
can't
say that these are marginally invariant
and now we could have a discussion later
on about how maybe they shouldn't be
marginally invariant because they have
different numbers of neighbors right so
maybe that we do know something about
them but
with our structures right now we
actually can't impose this implicit
assumption that we had been making all
the time that they are marginally
invariant right that was the assumption
that we were making and so
more importantly this markovian
relational representation that we're
using doesn't even allow us to
specify this constraint or ensure this
constraint because of the way the models
are rolled out over the network and so
what rong jing did um as part of her
thesis was to think about whether there
was an alternative approach um and
to where we could and should impose this
constraint in the model and i won't go
into the details because i don't have
enough time but
essentially what we did is use a copula
based representation where we're able to
transform between
uh dependent structure across all the
nodes where we used a latent variable
across this the graph structure which
i'll show you in a second and then we
were able to transform between that
joint dependent structure and marginals
by using a copula formulation and so
this is what the model looks like here
let me back up so you can think of what
what we did was actually construct an
iid classifier where the effect of the
attributes on the class label
goes through a
hidden variable here z and then what we
do is we combine that with this joint
representation right here where now
we model the dependence between the z's
as this latent variable
t which then is rolled out over the
network and that's way too complicated
to get into here
but the sort of key point here is that
because we can separate the marginal
representation from the joint
representation we're able to constrain
the nodes to have identical marginals
okay so that's the key point that i
wanted to make
another
sort of interesting point i wanted to
bring up
so the way that we
tie these together is that we have a
latent variable latent continuous
variable these t's that we model jointly
which actually then might be similar to
what art was talking about
earlier which we'll have to talk more
afterwards about that but then we have
just a simple logistic regression on
each node that includes
works the attributes in and
gives us a
variable that then will use the sign of
that to
do our classification and so again i'm
very much glossing over the details but
the important and sort of interesting
thing
uh that resulted from that is that being
able to impose this condition that we
have marginal and variance means that
across a wide set of
i thought these would all animate out
for you so
this shows you an example of the kind of
results we see on real data
compared to a number of different kinds
of relational models here including some
that are more feature based like this
social dim model
and the this rmn is the
markovian relational model
here's the copula model that does um as
good or significantly better than all of
the current models across a wide range
of conditions and i should point out
that here our x-axis is how many labels
we have in the test data set right
and so what this shows us obviously it's
great if we do better we can get a paper
published out of it
but um
what this the key idea here i want to
point out is that being able to actually
put this
assumption of marginal invariance into
the model seems to be the thing that
allows us to have this gain and
performance right and so this is
something that we did not really think
about as an effect of the graph
structure and to be able to
deal uh constrain this while still
dealing with this heterogeneous graph
structure we had to go through this
complex machinery of copula models right
but if we think about more of these
assumptions and how they interact with
the graph structure we maybe can get
ourselves to better and better kinds of
models okay
so now let me go on to finding number
two so finding number two is that
the typical ways of using ensembles um
that have been widely used in machine
learning to boost the performance that
we have i guess it's
odd that i use the word boost for there
right so boosting and bagging kind of
models that improve the performance that
we get the predictive accuracy
if we think about
extending those to
our relational domains then we have to
think about how to take structure into
account okay
so
basically
if you think about a bias variance
decomposition of the errors that we make
and classification now when we do these
collective inference procedures as we
roll out this graphical model and do
joint inference over the network we now
have an additional source of error
that's due to the inference process that
we use and so um
let me just jump into
that we have to be able to take that
into account as we develop these kind of
ensemble techniques and so just to show
you quickly what ensemble techniques
look like if you're not familiar with
them you in conventional data sets what
you would do is take a set of data that
you have somehow sample with replacement
from it or do something else
to get yourself many different sample
different versions of that data to learn
models from then you'll apply all of
those models to a test data set and do
some kind of averaging or aggregation of
your predictions in order to come up
with final predictions and so
they um
the sort of key components of these
different methods are how to sample the
data differently
so boosting will weight it differently
after you make predictions about it
bagging will sample with replacement etc
and then how to aggregate the results at
the end whether you weight those results
or you do simple averaging so the
question is how to do this for network
domains well the key
issue that i know i've talked with a
number of you about is how do we sample
with replacement
or in some other way from graphs when
they're all interconnected and we want
to preserve the connectivity network
structure and the other issue is what
can we do
in here that takes into account that
we're doing collective inference
so
so very quickly
hoda in her dissertation worked on a
relational resampling method so that we
could get different versions of the same
graph to use for training and what we
ended up doing is sampling subgraphs
with replacement which sort of goes back
to this discussion we have about
clusters as being the sort of
informative units of the graph we have a
relatively ad hoc way of connecting
those cl those sub graphs back up to
produce a large graph so there's a lot
more work that could be done in this
area but then we also developed a way to
do
interleaving of the collective inference
processes to aggregate instead of
waiting to the end of the collective
inference process we aggregate the
predictions during the collective
inference process and so what that would
look like is that you have three graphs
here where the edges between them
the nodes are all the same but the edges
between them might be different because
of the different graphs and what you're
going to do is you're going to be making
a prediction
with one model in one graph but you have
three different graphs that you've
sampled with replacement and what you'll
do is make your individual predictions
you might not have been able to catch
that but this node right here is mostly
blue and this is mostly blue but in this
graph they think it's mostly yellow
right and so what we'll do is we'll
average those predictions before we go
to the next round of inference and this
guy will become mostly blue because the
other ones were blue right and so this
interleaving of the aggregation while
we're doing collective inference
helps to prevent errors being propagated
through the network because of some
strange graph structure that you're
seeing just because of variants in the
data okay
and so here's some results
that sort of break down the gains that
we get both from how we do resampling so
we could do
relational resampling or iid resampling
and we can combine that with our on a
collective ensemble which is this
interleaving process
or not and this is the single model that
we have right here and so we get the
kind of gains you'd expect to see based
on
the theory for
bagging kind of results and the another
thing i should note is that the gains
get reduced as we have more and more
labels in the graph right so these kind
of bagging type approaches are going to
work better
or have more impact when there's fewer
things we know in the graph
and so
hoda and her dissertation and i think
one of our papers has a whole bunch of
theory where she works this out for
for
taking the bagging type theory to a
relational setting to prove
that compared to
a single model
in the domain
if we use a simple relational ensemble
where we don't interleave things we're
going to at least keep the variance the
same or reduce it and then if we use a
collective ensemble where we interleave
them
we're going to further reduce the
variance right so we can prove that we
are going to reduce the variance but the
thing that i wanted to point out here is
that in the proof of these um
this methods
it's
very interesting that we did not
consider the graph structure right so so
our proof is really at the level of the
predictive model which is the whys that
we're trying to predict right and so
we're kind of hand wavy by saying that
our graphs
not we're not saying that the graphs are
drawn from the same distribution
but we're saying the models of the y's
are drawn from the same distribution
when we resample the network right so
it's a very tricky way to try to prove
things and we just did it the best way
we could but what i wanted to point out
was that
i've thought a lot about
if we model the graph distribution can
we say things about how our graphical
models are going to perform given a
particular kind of graph structure and
most of the time i argue that we need
more work on how to model the graphs so
that we can do a better job of saying
these things but actually this theory
that we're working on says maybe perhaps
there's a different way to approach it
which is to say let's just punt on how
to model the graphs if we can say that
the processes which are rolled out on
the graphs are the same then the graphs
are essentially equivalent for us
which might have some relationship to
what matt and arun were talking about
earlier in the week right so if we can
take a step above and say that we don't
we can sort of not care at the base
level about this exact graph that we
have but go one step up and say we're
going to think about something at a
higher level that might help a little
bit more with their theory and because
i'm running out of time i'm going to
skip the last
finding i am running out of time right
michael yeah
so i'm going to skip the last finding
and
well maybe i'll just put it up here and
so that you can talk about it
afterwards with me if you're interested
so the last set of work was thinking
about model selection and how if we
learn in a fully labeled network and we
apply the models in a partially labeled
network then the performance of the
models that we've learned is going to
differ
based on the graph structure that you
have in your test data and the location
of that label availability now this is
what i was showing at the beginning
because if somebody breaks you know if
we know this high degree node in the
middle we know it's labeled and it
breaks everything apart certain models
might perform better
than if you have only peripheral
information that still keeps a big blob
in your graphical model right and so i
will
not talk about the details of that but
if you're interested in that specific
set of work you can talk to me about it
afterwards so just in conclusion
we've had
a lot of empirical success that shows
that in many data sets if we can
incorporate these relational
dependencies into our models we can do a
better job of prediction
but
what we've
not paid attention to is how this graph
structure here affects the
characteristics of our models and so
even though we're doing fairly well
empirically i my my feeling is that if
we had a better understanding of uh sort
of analytically or theoretically how
this graph structure impacts the
performance of these models we'd really
be able to push our methods to exploit
that information even more so than what
we're doing right now and so
having a better characterization of this
graph structure i think is really needed
uh to be pulled into the machine
learning community and put together with
a lot of the theoretical frameworks that
we have already in machine learning so i
will stop there thank you